we need heroes we need you
Captain Marvel is about somebody who
goes on a journey of discovery and I
think it was really important for breeds
learn how to fight by the time we
started shooting I had been training for
nine months and I'm glad that I did
doing my sequences up and down or
training for three days
well minimalize
the thing that I found so unique about
this character was that sense of humor
mixed with total capability and whatever
challenge comes her way you know how to
fly this thing you see which I realized
after going to Air Force Base is really
what Air Force pilots are like that's a
yes or no question yes
and we simulated a dogfight we were on
offense we were on the defense we got to
6.5 G's is amazing it's a lot a lot of
work she brings so much of that to the
role it's pretty awesome
[Music]
a vendor's endgame we now know the title
how long did we did you know the title
was the title in place during production
it was in place before that before we
started developing the movie or just as
we were developing it yes
so Doctor Strange says that line because
we knew it was the title there's talk
that in the marketing of it obviously
seen the first trailer which presumably
doesn't show us much at all that in the
market and you're never gonna show us
much past say the first 15 or 20 minutes
of the movie is that kind of strategy is
that
somewhat accurate I call it somewhat
accurate yeah I think I think as was the
case with a lot of our films this one in
particular you know being able to
generate excitement without giving away
any of the many many many many secrets
honey many many many secrets will be
would be ideal and I think the Disney
marketing team is the best in the world
and we'll be able to to pull it off I
know you spoke recently about obviously
the coming merger and it's a little
premature to get too deep into things I
don't know if you heard I spoke to McKay
the other day Adam McKay said Silver
Surfer movie I might you know I might
need to give Feige a call have you
gotten the call I've not gotten a call
yet but I've seen Adam tonight and at a
number of these awards and he is not
only as everybody knows incredibly smart
guy he's a honest-to-goodness fan and
and you know he did a lot of sort of
behind the scenes help with us on the
first Batman film and have you seen Vice
cameo little practice cameo in there
that we help them get so I look forward
to speaking with him or if there is
there a Fox property or you're just
excited to potentially get your hands on
a particular the truth is I'm excited
for all of them I'm excited and it's not
just a marquee names you know there are
hundreds of names on those on those
documents on those agreements and the
fact that Marvel is as close as we may
ever get now to having access to all of
the characters is something I've been
dreaming about for my almost 20 years
at marble and it's very exciting last
thing for you is there any status on
Guardians 3 in terms of like what you're
thinking you're gonna do with that in
terms of finding another director and
I'm curious also like thoughts on James
potentially getting into the DC Universe
is that bittersweet for you
you know I went to see Aquaman last
night and I really really enjoyed it so
and you know me I've always supported I
don't see a rivalry I see coole films
being made and James got one thing you
know about James Gunn he makes cool
films guardians will happen when we're
how for a later time hey everybody is
Charlie we got a whole bunch of new
Captain Marvel and Avengers endgame to
break down thanks to Kevin Feige at the
Golden Globes the other night and
obviously they just dropped that big
Captain Marvel trailer I already did a
video for that so I'll link it at the
end of this but because we're getting so
close to the Superbowl and their big
press tour I guess they're just trying
to blitz everyone with new Captain
Marvel brie Larson footage will do a new
round of that IMAX ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite Kevin
Feige moment on the video it could be
from anything that he's ever done in the
history of Marvel Studios you probably
want to hear about all the Kevin Feige
stuff first then I guess we'll talk
about the new brie Larson footage
there's mostly just behind the scenes of
her fighting Scrolls and talking about
her flight training with the air force
people I think the Kevin Feige stuff is
a little more timely so I just broke
this down top 5 style but he talks about
a number of different things relating to
Avengers endgame during this interview
so 5 he talks about how they picked the
title for avengers endgame this is
actually really interesting because he
says that they knew what it was going to
be before they started developing the
movie and they developed avengers
endgame around the same time that they
were developing infinity war so like
both of those films were like this one
big project that they sort of demarcated
with the snap even though the beginning
of the process they were marketing it as
part 1 and part 2 they came out pretty
quickly after that I think it was in
2016 to say you know no no no it's not
actually gonna be called part 2 it'll be
a different title a very different movie
it's just internally we were calling it
that for a little while so he confirms
that they very specifically gave dr.
strange that line of dialogue from
infinity war because they knew that the
title was going to be endgame retro
actively there's that Avengers age of
Ultron Ironman line where he says that
up there that's endgame no one has said
whether or not they
asked joss whedon to add that line
specifically for the same reason like oh
we're gonna be calling this final movie
Avengers endgame so let's start teasing
that as soon as Avengers age of Ultron
Whedon was writing the script for that
so long ago unless they say otherwise
I'm just assuming that it's a
coincidence that works out in their
favor in the same way that say like that
spider-man Iron Man 2 Easter Egg wasn't
originally meant to be a Spider Man
moment but when you contextualize it
like that with new information it just
makes the universe fit together a lot
better
Tom Holland was the one that originally
came up with that idea when someone
asked him in an interview hey are you
that little kid with the Iron Man mask
in Iron Man 2 he thought it was a great
idea Kevin Feige thought it was a great
idea even though originally they didn't
intend it that way because nobody knew
at the time the Spider Man would
eventually join the universe when they
were making Iron Man 2 you may also
remember after infinity war came out and
we started to try and guess what the
title of Avengers 4 was the Russos did
interviews saying to a journalist in a
now-infamous interview that the title of
Avengers 4 was not spoken at all during
infinity war which Kevin Feige is now
saying is not true like they
specifically added the title of Avengers
4 to Doctor Strange his dialogue because
they knew what the title would be so you
got to feel bad for some of those
journalists that the Russos just threw
right under the bus hopefully the Russos
will just say no comment if they don't
want to give away spoilers in the future
because it makes it harder to trust what
they say when they are telling the truth
like boy who cried wolf like you lie a
couple times people will stop believing
everything you say for Kevin Feige
confirms that most of the trailer
footage we're going to see will be from
earlier in the film the journalist
that's asking him says first 15 to 20
minutes and Kevin Feige says that's kind
of accurate so that doesn't mean that we
won't see footage from later in the film
but for the most part these early
trailers will be stuff from earlier just
to keep away the really big costume
changes and the really big spoilers 3 he
talks a little bit more about the Fox
Disney deal closing getting the x-men
and Fantastic Four characters back he
hasn't said a whole lot about what's
going on with Dark Phoenix but I'm sure
when we get closer to that movie coming
out he'll start more directly addressing
it like how do you feel about all these
Fox x-men films how do you feel like
they close it down or are you going to
recast all of these people but like I
said in previous videos I think that
their next big comic-con panel or
wherever their next big Marvel phase 4
panel happens that's when we'll find out
specifically what his plans are for them
but to really fund detail he talks more
about Adam McKay's sofort surfer movie
obviously he's really excited to work
with him Adam McKay was actually asked
to help write and develop spider-man far
from home but he says that he was too
busy working on his movie vise with
Christian Bale which is like the Dick
Cheney movie which Kevin Feige also says
they helped them get a Galactus cameo in
if you haven't seen that movie obviously
it has nothing to do with comic books
but it has a small Galactus cameo in it
but I love the idea of an Adam McKay
Silver Surfer movie if anybody's gonna
do like a really weird cosmic movie in
the MCU I feel like Adam McKay would do
a good job with that but then finally he
addresses what's going on with guardians
of the galaxy 3 and he even talks a
little bit about James Gunn and says
that he loved
Aquaman which i think is great he's like
a total class act in this interview
there's no rivalry we're all just making
really awesome movies right now
early rumor is is that what'll happen
later this year is that they'll lock
down their director and they'll shoot
guardians of the galaxy 3 sometime early
mid next year but a lot of that just
depends on how long it takes them to
find their new director but right now it
seems like they're still going to be
using James Gunn's
original script Adam warlock is in that
script so if you're waiting for him to
appear in the MCU it's not gonna happen
during Avengers endgame it was
originally going to happen during
guardians 3 that was originally supposed
to start shooting this year so just
imagine that being pushed by about a
year but for the most part everything's
in place all the actors are still signed
they'll still come back and shoot it so
what'll happen is they'll be more Marvel
videos happening later this week I'm
working on new Game of Thrones leave all
your video requests in the comments
below
congratulations power of pop you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
the original ant-man and the wasp or a
late 80s thing Janet Van Dyne
disappeared in the late 80s Captain
Marvel is early 90s there are rumors
about a young version of Tony Stark Iron
Man appearing in a cameo in Captain
Marvel but I'll talk about that in a
separate video so click here for that
brand-new Captain Marvel trailer and
click here for that brand-new Game of
Thrones teaser trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight
[Music]